An ex-bowling prodigy with a rubber hand
and a now-faceless terrorist back from
the dead... These iconic characters and more
are on their way back to a screen near you.
It's time for a new generation of kids to worry
about shooting their eyes out. Several decades
after the classic holiday film A Christmas
Story was first released, a sequel is in
the works. A Christmas Story Christmas will
bring back Peter Billingsley as Ralphie, the
elementary school-aged protagonist of the first
film, now all grown up and facing the holidays
yet again. Also returning for the sequel are
Ian Petrella as Ralphie's brother, Randy,
along with Zack Ward, Scott Schwartz, and R.D.
Robb as Ralphie's trio of friends from school.
The story follows Ralphie's return to
his childhood home in an attempt to
give his children a Christmas like the ones he
experienced as a kid. According to Deadline,
"Ralphie reconnects with childhood friends,
reconciles the passing of his Old Man,
and sows the seeds for the origins
of the beloved holiday classic."
A Christmas Story Christmas
hits HBO Max on November 17,
2022 and is directed by Clay
Kaytis and written by Nick Schenk.
In 2020, Disney confirmed that a fifth installment
in the iconic Indiana Jones franchise is on the
way, once again starring Indy himself, Harrison
Ford. At 78 years old, Ford will likely retire
his trademark whip and fedora by the end of
Indiana Jones 5, although the studio hasn't
indicated whether he'll pass the baton to a
younger generation or close out the franchise.
"You show up every day. You do your
job. And then they just let you go."
We do know he'll be joined in his adventure
by Phoebe Waller-Bridge of Fleabag fame,
playing Indy's goddaughter, Helena.
Mads Mikkelsen from Hannibal will
play the villain. He'll be joined
by Oscar nominee Antonio Banderas,
and John Rhys-Davies will again play
Indy's trusted companion Sallah.
In the director's chair for Indiana Jones 5 is
James Mangold. Mangold directed 2017's Logan,
which served as the sendoff for Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine and Patrick Stewart's Charles Xavier.
Logan offered a thrilling and satisfying
ending for Jackman and Stewart's characters,
and earned Mangold an Academy Award nomination
for Best Adapted Screenplay. While Indiana Jones
5 isn't likely to skew as dark as Logan, we
hope the farewell to our favorite archaeology
professor will be just as moving when
the film hits theaters on June 30, 2023.
In the age of sequels, remakes, and reboots of
what feels like every significant film ever made,
revisiting one of cinema's most iconic
horror movies was inevitable. Sure enough,
The Exorcist 2, 3 and 4 are in the
works from fright factory Blumhouse.
The original Exorcist centers on a 12-year-old
girl, played by Linda Blair, who's possessed
by a terrifying demon. Her mother, played by
Ellen Burstyn, hires a pair of priests, played
by Jason Miller and Max von Sydow, to perform
an exorcism. Spoiler alert: both priests died
in the original film, and Miller and von Sydow
have since passed on, as well. But Burstyn will
be returning to assist new protagonist Leslie Odom
Jr. as he seeks help for his own possessed child.
The first film in the new Exorcist trilogy
will be released in theaters on October 13,
2023, although there's a possibility the
following two films could premiere on Peacock.
As far as bizarre action movie premises go,
it doesn't get much weirder than
Face/Off. In this bizarre blockbuster,
Nicolas Cage and John Travolta star as a
terrorist and an FBI agent, respectively,
who literally swap faces via a gnarly surgery
in order to each take each other's place.
Even though – spoiler alert – Cage's
villainous Castor Troy is killed at the
end of the first film, a direct sequel is now
in the works from filmmakers Adam Wingard and
Simon Barrett. Barrett and Wingard were quick
to clarify on social media that they have no
intention of reimagining the original, which
Wingard considers "a perfect action movie."
Speaking to the Associated Press,
Cage expressed enthusiasm at the possibility
of reprising his role in the sequel, saying,
"I would love to get back into that
character and to work with Travolta."
"God, I miss that face."
Wingard has expressed interest in seeing
Cage return, telling Empire Online,
"He's just having such a moment.
[...] A couple of years ago,
the studio maybe would have wanted
a hot, young, up-and-coming actor or
something. Now, Nicolas Cage is one of
the hottest actors in Hollywood again."
Of course, as Cage's character is dead, so
it'll be interesting to see how they bring
him back. But in a world as crazy
as Face/Off, anything is possible.
On his 35th birthday, Julius Benedict,
played by Arnold Schwarzenegger,
discovered he was separated at birth from his
twin brother, Vincent, played by Danny DeVito,
after they were conceived in a lab as part
of a genetic experiment. Twins followed the
unlikely duo as they reconnected and
uncovered the secrets of their past.
Thirty-three years later, the Benedict
clan is expanding once again in Triplets.
This time Schwarzenegger and DeVito
will be joined by Tracy Morgan as
a yet-unnamed third brother. Twins
director Ivan Reitman was slated to
direct the sequel until his death in 2022. In
describing the sequel, Reitman told Deadline,
"They don't know each other, and very early
in the movie, they meet. It's how they
achieve a bond together after all these
years. It's really a film about family,
and no matter how different we all
are, we have to learn to get along."
Originally, the film was set to
begin shooting in 2022 from a
script penned by Dylan Dawson and Lucas
Kavner. Without Reitman at the helm,
we wouldn't be surprised if
production gets pushed back.
It was just a matter of time before the
bizarre 1988 Tim Burton haunted house
comedy Beetlejuice got the sequel treatment.
Sure enough, Beetlejuice 2 is finally in the
works from Brad Pitt's production company
Plan B, with Michael Keaton and Winona
Ryder expected to reprise their roles from
the first film. Beetlejuice starred Keaton
"If you don't let me gut out
this house and make it my own,
I will go insane and I will take you with me!"
However, nothing goes according to plan. Lydia
Deetz, the new homeowners' quirky teenage
daughter, played by Ryder, only narrowly escapes
being married off to him. By the end of the film,
the Deetzes and the Maitlands are happily
cohabitating, with Beetlejuice banished to
a waiting room for the non-living. Although the
script for Beetlejuice 2 hasn't yet been written,
we imagine it will find him finally
returning to find Lydia all grown up. How
his path will cross that of his reluctant
ex-fiancée is currently anyone's guess.
Directed by the one and only John Carpenter,
the 1986 fantasy-adventure Big Trouble in
Little China follows trucker Jack Burton,
played by Kurt Russell, as he's drawn into
the mystical underbelly of San Francisco's
Chinatown. Hoping to save a kidnapped woman
from the forces of darkness, Burton encounters
ninjas, monsters, and an ancient sorcerer.
With its mythic warriors and magical sword fights,
Big Trouble in Little China has become
a classic, so, naturally, people were
concerned when a remake with Dwayne Johnson was
announced in 2015. As it turns out, however,
the next film will actually be a sequel. Speaking
to Collider, producer Hiram Garcia admitted,
"You can't remake a classic like [Big
Trouble], so what we're planning to do
is continue the story. We're going to continue
the universe of Big Trouble in Little China."
Garcia went on to explain that the events
of the first film will still exist in the
new Dwayne Johnson movie, but the Rock
will be playing a brand new character.
While that leaves room for Russell's return,
the actor has said that he "probably won't
be" in the sequel. Fans will definitely
miss seeing Jack Burton back in action.
We thought the day would never come, but it looks
like Ridley Scott is heading back to ancient Rome.
"At my signal, unleash hell."
Nearly 20 years after the original
Gladiator hit theaters, Scott is
finally making a sequel to the story
of Maximus Decimus Meridius. Of course,
Maximus is busy walking through wheat fields in
heaven, so what's the sequel going to be about?
According to producer Walter F. Parkes, the
film starts 25 to 30 years after the original
ended. And according to The Hollywood
Reporter, part two will focus on Lucius,
the son of Maximus' old flame, Lucilla. It does
sound like Connie Nielsen, who played Lucilla,
could come back. Speaking to Collider, Nielsen
said that the sequel was still planned,
and when asked if she'd be willing
to return to the role, she said,
"It would obviously be amazing, and I know
that a lot of people want to see more of that."
Scott revealed in late 2021 that
the script is already complete,
and Gladiator 2 is queued up to be the
director's next project once he's finished
with Napoleon. With Scott at the helm,
we're pretty sure we'll be entertained.
Fans of the 1996 bowling comedy Kingpin are
in luck because a sequel is rolling down
the pipeline. The original film featured Woody
Harrelson as a former bowling prodigy who believes
he's found his meal ticket when he discovers an
Amish bowling superstar, played by Randy Quaid.
"Fourteen karat gold."
"Really? Looks like rubber."
"No. The ring, not the hand."
The film also starred Bill Murray
as Harrelson's lifelong rival,
as well as Vanessa Angel,
Chris Elliott, and Lin Shaye.
No details have yet been revealed about the
sequel other than that Peter and Bobby Farrelly,
who directed the first film, will be back on
board to produce Kingpin 2. However, it's unclear
whether the Farrelly brothers are intending to
write or direct the sequel in addition to their
producing duties. Similarly, none of the original
cast is confirmed to be returning, although
fans would surely welcome another chance to see
Harrelson and Murray together on the big screen.
Jim Henson's cult classic Labyrinth
has a diehard following thanks to
its creepily fantastical storytelling,
imaginative creature creations, and,
of course, an iconic performance from
David Bowie as Jareth the Goblin King.
"I wish the goblins would come and take you away."
Making a sequel to Henson's final feature
film is a pretty intimidating task,
but the Jim Henson Company feels up to it.
News of the Labyrinth sequel first broke in 2017,
with Don't Breathe filmmaker Fede Alvarez
attached to direct. However, Alvarez announced
in April of 2020 that he was stepping away
from the film. He told Bloody Disgusting,
"I just decided I didn't want to do things
as a director that people knew already what
it was. Or have a preconceived notion of how it
should look on the screen. So Labyrinth would
be something that people would judge
that way, so I decided not to do it."
Fortunately, the project didn't stay rudderless
for long. In May of 2020, Deadline reported
that Doctor Strange director Scott Derrickson had
stepped in to helm the highly anticipated sequel.
Maggie Levin, the writer and director of Into
the Dark, will write the screenplay. We don't
have any details about the plot, but back when
Alvarez was attached, project insiders confirmed
to The Hollywood Reporter that the sequel would
be a continuation of the story that began in the
original film. As Bowie has passed on, however,
the Goblin King will not be making an appearance.
The first Lethal Weapon hit theaters in 1987,
introducing audiences to the buddy cop duo
of Riggs, played by Mel Gibson, and Murtaugh,
played by Danny Glover. Since then, it's spawned
three sequels and a television series. However,
with no new Lethal Weapon films since
Lethal Weapon 4 in 1998, it was a surprise
to learn that Warner Brothers intended to
reinvigorate the franchise with a new entry.
Prior to the death of acclaimed director
Richard Donner — who directed the first
four Lethal Weapon films in addition to
Superman and The Goonies — producer Dan
Lin said that the fifth film was
particularly special to Donner,
who was attached to direct. In 2020,
Lin told The Hollywood Reporter,
"We're trying to make the last Lethal
Weapon' movie. Donner's coming back.
The original cast is coming back. And
it's just amazing. The story itself is
very personal to him and to the cast,
and so I really want to make that one."
Of course, none of that may pan out,
as Donner passed away in 2021. However,
in the wake of the filmmaker's death,
Mel Gibson has confirmed that he is
in talks to take over directorial duties,
although a deal has not yet been reached.
It's been almost 20 years since audiences
followed effervescent sorority girl Elle Woods to
Harvard Law School in the bubblegum-hued Legally
Blonde. She continued to ascend the professional
ladder in 2003's Legally Blonde 2: Red, White &
Blonde, which saw Elle head to Washington, D.C.
"Hello, Patriots!"
Now Elle is back, along with producer Marc
Platt and Platt Productions president Adam
Siegel. In addition to playing Elle, Reese
Witherspoon is producing through her Hello
Sunshine banner. She's brought on Never Have I
Ever creator Mindy Kaling and Brooklyn Nine-Nine
creator Dan Goor to pen the screenplay. Also
returning for the sequel is Jennifer Coolidge,
who starred in both previous
films as Elle's friend Paulette.
"I love snow globes. I can hear the ocean!"
There will be "a lot of new
faces" in Legally Blonde 3,
and a lot more diversity. Kaling told E! Online,
"Reflecting the world as it is now is something
that's really important to Reese, and so having
there be like diversity is super, super
important. You can definitely count on that."
A fan of the original film, Kaling is looking
forward to revisiting an older and wiser – and
likely even more fabulous – Elle Woods. In
an interview with Access Hollywood, she said,
"I can't wait to see what Elle Woods — what
people will think of the way we wrote Elle
Woods at 40. How Elle Woods is at 40 versus how
she was at 21 has been really fun to imagine."
But for those who worry that Elle may have
outgrown the Bend and Snap, Kaling reassured fans,
"Bend and Snap is forever. We definitely have a
lot of fan favorites from the original movie."
Despite nearly four decades having passed since
The Last Starfighter first wowed audiences,
the time may be ideal for a sequel. Starfighter
is about a teenager who beats a video game,
only to discover that the game is
really a recruiting tool looking
for soldiers to fight an interstellar alien war.
"I've seen 'em come and I've
seen 'em go, but you're the best,
my boy. Dazzling. Light years ahead of the
competition. Which is why Centauri is here."
Video games have changed a lot since then, which
presents an interesting way to continue the
story. Speaking to Moviehole, Jonathan Betuel, the
writer of the original film, said of the sequel,
"It's not a remake. It's going to continue the
story. What's changed is time itself, certainly as
the video world and the alien world have continued
to tick away. It's not a time capsule of the
'80s by any means, we're taking it to the next
level. Passing the torch ... or the joystick."
Betuel will be co-writing the sequel, titled
The Last Starfighters, with Rogue One:
A Star Wars Story screenwriter
Gary Whitta. In March 2021,
Whitta tweeted a sizzle reel that teases the
plot of the film. From what we can gather,
the story involves an alien attempting to
assassinate an adult Alex, the protagonist
of the first film. Alex then heads off into
space to get to the bottom of things. It's
been a long road, but Betuel is optimistic
the sequel will finally get off the ground.
The last National Treasure film hit
theaters back in 2007. In other words,
it's been a long time since we've
seen Benjamin Franklin Gates.
"The treasure is a myth."
"I refuse to believe that."
There have long been rumors of a third National
Treasure film, and while at times the project
has seemed as lost as an ancient stash of gold,
it looks like a new installment is finally on
the way. In May 2022, producer Jerry Bruckheimer
confirmed the film is in progress, with a script
by Bad Boys for Life scribe Chris Bremner. The
next step was to send the finished screenplay to
original franchise star Nicolas Cage. The
project is apparently still in the works,
despite Disney moving forward with Disney+
series National Treasure: Edge of History.
Along with Clerks 3, another Kevin Smith script
that got polished during the 2020 lockdown is
the sequel to 1995's Mallrats, which he penned
under the working title Twilight of the Mallrats.
The plot of the original film revolves around a
dating show being filmed at a shopping mall, and
stars Jeremy London, Jason Lee, Claire Forlani,
Shannen Doherty, Ben Affleck, and Michael Rooker.
This time, instead of a game show,
the plot will focus on a convention taking
place at the mall. According to Smith,
"The whole thing is, there's
a big convention at the mall,
so there's plenty of places and
opportunities [for things to happen]."
Smith has revealed that the entire principal
cast of the first film will be appearing in
the second. He even confirmed that iconic comic
book creator Stan Lee, who passed away in 2018,
will have a scene to parallel his cameo in the
first movie. Smith confided to ComicBook.com,
"The thing I feel most clever about in regard to
the movie, obviously one of us can't come back,
right? Stan's gone. So, there is a Stan Lee
scene, and it makes absolute perfect sense.".
Joining the team for Twilight of the
Mallrats is newcomer Aparna Brielle,
whom Smith says will be at the
center of the sequel. He tweeted,
"I was so impressed with [Brielle], I built my
next flick around her. Aparna will play Brodie
Bruce's daughter Banner in the movie I hope
to shoot next — TWILIGHT OF THE MALLRATS."
Twilight of the Mallrats is likely to
wind up as a Peacock exclusive release.
It's been more than 30 years since we last saw
the fuzzy little nightmares who shouldn't be
fed after midnight, but it sounds like the
Gremlins could be returning to theaters in
a new horrific adventure. A sequel to the
original movie, Gremlins 2: The New Batch,
was released in 1990. Original Gremlins
screenwriter Chris Columbus has apparently
been working on getting a third Gremlins off
the ground. In November 2020, he told Collider,
"I would love to do it. I wrote a script [...]
We're working out some rights issues right now,
so we're just trying to figure out when
the best time to make that film would
be. I would still do it the same way -– I
would do it as tangible puppets, not CGI."
The "rights issues" involve Warner Brothers,
which now owns the name and franchise and
greenlit an animated Gremlins series for
HBO Max called Gremlins: Secrets of the Mogwai.
Still, Gremlins director Joe Dante told /Film,
"I think it's inevitable. The title is too well
known to not do something with. So eventually
somebody's going to do something with it, which
is fine as long as there isn't too much CGI."
RoboCop is back. According to Deadline, the cyborg
is returning to the big screen, although it seems
the new film's going to mess with continuity. The
original RoboCop was directed by Paul Verhoeven,
and it made a killing when it was released
in 1987. After two sequels in the early '90s,
the franchise was rebooted in 2014 with actor
Joel Kinnaman and director Jose Padilha.
The latest entry in the franchise will be called
RoboCop Returns, and will feature a fresh cast.
In November 2019, Orion Pictures announced that
Little Monsters director Abe Forsythe had taken
up the helm of RoboCop Returns. The screenplay
was originally written in 1998 by Ed Neumeier
and Michael Miner, the scribes behind the first
film, with director Forsythe giving it a rewrite.
Neumeier had nothing but good things to say
about the new version, telling Syfy Wire,
"What he came back with was really interesting,
it felt relevant and really crackled."
Dave Stevens' '80s cult comic book The Rocketeer
clearly took inspiration from mid-century movie
matinee adventure serials, and, in 1991, things
came full circle when Disney brought the story
to the big screen. Billy Campbell starred as
Cliff Secord, a 1930s stunt pilot living in
Los Angeles who finds a jetpack that allows him
to soar through the sky while evading the FBI,
its inventor Howard Hughes, and the Nazis who
want it badly. Disney thought it could launch
a trilogy, but, when the film underperformed
at the box office, sequel plans were dead.
In 2020, the company started work on a
legacy-style sequel to be titled The Return of the
Rocketeer. Now You See Me screenwriter Ed Ricourt
is writing the film, with actor David Oyelowo
producing and possibly starring. The upcoming
Rocketeer movie will follow a new character,
a retired member of the famed Tuskegee Airmen who
becomes the latest pilot to strap on the fantastic
jetpack. While we don't know when it will be
released, we do know it will land on Disney+.
We are in the midst of an Eddie Murphy
renaissance. After his heyday in the
'80s and early '90s, Murphy faded from the
spotlight. He's suddenly back in a big way,
giving a critically acclaimed performance
in 2019's Dolemite Is My Name, making a
triumphant return to Saturday Night Live as host,
lining up new standup comedy special for Netflix,
and announcing a sequel to one of his
biggest movie hits, Beverly Hills Cop.
"Yes, you have a reservation for an Axel Foley."
Marking the fourth installment in
the Beverly Hills Cop franchise,
the latest sequel will be a collaboration between
Murphy and Netflix, since Paramount pulled the
plug on Beverly Hills Cop 4 back in 2016. Murphy
will be back as Axel Foley, the Detroit cop who
repeatedly finds himself investigating crimes
in Beverly Hills. Directing will be Mark Molloy,
a rising filmmaker who's earned positive
attention for his Apple commercials.
Murphy has said he's ready to go as soon as the
script is complete, and Will Beall, best known
for story credits on Aquaman and Zack Snyder's
Justice League, has taken on Beverly Hills Cop:
Axel Foley. Joining Murphy will be Zola breakout
star Taylour Paige and veteran actors Joseph
Gordon-Levitt and Kevin Bacon. Additionally,
Judge Reinhold tweeted some photos in September
2022 that hint he'll return as Foley's partner
in crime fighting, Detective Billy Rosewood.
After writing and directing the classic
indie horror movies The Evil Dead and Evil
Dead II — but before he became the A-lister
behind the original Spider-Man trilogy — Sam
Raimi ventured into the superhero realm for
the first time with Darkman. It's a dark,
comic book-like revenge thriller about a scientist
who's presumed dead, but instead dons a hat,
trench coat, and thick facial bandages to take
revenge on the bad guys who nearly burned him
to death. Oh, yeah, he's also super strong and
can create new faces out of experimental skin,
but his disguises are sensitive
to light, so they never last long.
Darkman was one of the first big movies for
future superstar Liam Neeson and three-time Oscar
winner Frances McDormand. A couple of obscure,
straight-to-video sequels to Darkman already
exist. Raimi had nothing to do with those, and
he'd love to revisit the Darkman world. In 2022,
he told TheWrap that his sequel was in
the extremely early stages of development.
"There's a producer attached. I haven't heard the
story yet or gone into it. But I think it's cool."
Nothing in the way of creative crew, cast, or
release date has officially been confirmed.